there has been politics involved here
and this is the point we've tried to
make throughout which is stop the
politics in schools let us teach
children and let us make sure that kids
particularly these high school kids have
this kind of elective that that would be
really good in this country right now in
terms of African-American studies and
that's what DeSantis is trying to stop
he's treating the College Board like he
has treated Disney as if he alone makes
decisions about the educational needs of
kids as opposed to teachers and parents
oh so she was disappointed because she
wanted AP African-American studies to
teach gender queer theory apgov is
wildly different than this nonsense they
never address what's actually in any of
the things they just go with the bumper
sticker thing don't say gay well I'm
gonna say gay nobody's telling you not
to say gay lady